Speaker 1: Well, another day and another major
legislative accomplishment for Joe Biden,
whose presidency in the last two months, as I told
you about yesterday and the day before, has really
turned itself around. The Inflation Reduction
Act has now been signed into law by President Joe
Biden. This bill, you might recall, barely passed
the U.S. Senate, 5150. But, sir, how could it add
up to 101 votes? Well, it was 5050 with Kamala
Harris as vice president. Is the president of
the Senate casting the tie breaking vote, 51. That
was on August 7th. There were no Republican votes.
We also saw the bill on Friday passed the U.S.
House not particularly widely by a 222 207 margin.
And Joe Biden has now signed the bill into law.
And it is indeed major, major legislation. Let's
take a look at what this bill does. It is a more
than $430 billion package expected to reduce the
deficit by over $300 billion over ten years.
It's expected to raise $737 billion in revenue
over ten years. And it includes 369 billion in
investment money for climate and energy policy,
$64 billion to extend the Affordable Care Act
policy that reduces health insurance costs.
To be more honest, sometimes we can maybe more
accurately say is it slows down the rate of
increase for health insurance costs. It includes
importantly, notably, a 15% corporate minimum
tax for companies earning over $1,000,000,000
a year. This is a subject of much discussion,
which is for individuals. There has been an
alternative minimum tax for a long time, and the
concept of an alternative minimum tax is you make
$1,000,000 personally. You can use deductions and
losses and all these different things to offset
the full million in taxes, and you end up owing
zero in order to prevent that. Something called
the Alternative Minimum Tax was established, which
says that for a certain level of income, no matter
how many deductions and losses you have to offset
taxable income, you have to pay some minimum
tax. We never had that for corporations. This
bill puts that in place at a 15% rate. It also
puts in place a 1% tax on stock buybacks done by
large corporations. This was something that was
a big deal during the pandemic. You may recall
when the Donald Trump coronavirus stimuli
packages were enacted, many corporations
from the corporate side of it used the money
they got to just buy back their own stock,
raising its price. So this bill puts in place a
1% tax when you do stock buybacks. It will reduce
drug prices for Medicare recipients. It will it
expects to collect an additional $124 billion from
increased IRS enforcement. So there is money in
the bill controversially. So for many to hire more
IRS agents, the belief is that those additional
agents are going to find tax cheats and recover
124 billion additional dollars. It includes tax
credits to incentivize electric cars and electric
HVAC systems as well as other forms of cleaner
technology. That's great. And it is expected to
cut pollution by around 40% below the 25 level by
2030. And it also puts in place a $2,000 a year
out of pocket cap for Medicare recipients. Now, a
few thoughts on this. Number one, is this a major
legislative accomplishment for Joe Biden? Yes, it
is. Will people vote based on this in November?
It's not totally clear. We'll see what polling
suggests over the next probably 2 to 3 weeks,
regardless of your political persuasion. There
are things in this that are beneficial to most
of the Americans in the country. For example, the
$2,000 out-of-pocket cap for Medicare recipients.
Medicare recipients are both Democrats and
Republicans. In fact, we it's a more conservative
group. We know that every older cohort is slightly
more conservative in the United States right now,
less pollution as everybody benefits from
less pollution, even if you're against
green energy or whatever. All that. There are
things in here from which everyone benefits
regardless of political persuasion.
Now, I want to take a sort of political
overview of the Biden administration generally.
My philosophy is, generally speaking,
to judge presidents by what they do more than by
what they don't do. Now, there are exceptions to
that. For example, Donald Trump failed to do
many things in terms of his COVID response.
That is an area where you have an acute
situation. And it seems logical to say, look,
all these other world leaders did these things.
Trump failed to do that. That was an acute thing.
But there are people who wrote to me over the last
12 to 24 hours about the Inflation Reduction Act,
saying, David, this is not good for Biden.
What we need to be focusing on with Biden is
he hasn't decriminalize marijuana. He hasn't
forgiven all student debt, by the way. Joe Biden
did forgive a bunch more student debt overnight.
And we'll talk about that on the bonus show.
Joe Biden did not do X-Y-Z right. Trump also
didn't decriminalize marijuana. Obama didn't
decriminalize marijuana. It seems to me if we're
trying to evaluate a president's performance,
none of them decriminalize marijuana and it sort
of zeros out. I want cannabis decriminalized,
to be clear, but it seems weird to me to react to
what is clearly a major legislative accomplishment
and to say, Well, Biden hasn't done this other
thing. I tend to judge presidents by the things
that they do, and this is a very good thing.
This should be screamed from the rooftops on
media, social media, etc. by Democrats and
remind people you all benefit from things in
this bill. Even though every Republican in the
Senate voted against it. So are there things
Joe Biden has not done that I would like to see
him do? Absolutely. Have I been critical of Joe
Biden's lack of accomplishments? I have 100%. But
this is an accomplishment. The jobs numbers are
good. The economy is looking very good. Inflation
is coming down. The PACT Act has been signed
for people that think this type of thing is
good. He has gone and he approved the strike
that killed al Qaeda terrorist Ayman al-Zawahiri.
Many of you have concerns about due process. I
share those concerns. These are the things he has
done. And it makes absolute and perfect sense for
to give him credit for those and then compare to
the alternative when it comes time. If he runs
for reelection, what would this other person who
is eventually going to be the Republican nominee,
what would they have done in this situation? They
wouldn't have passed the Inflation Reduction Act.
They likely would not have passed the PACT
Act. They wouldn't have done a lot of the
things Joe Biden did that are good. And
then we evaluate, well, is it worthy of
reelection? That's a question for them down the
road. We don't even know if Biden is running.